Justin you told this prior to this
interview that you've contacted agency
after agency to find representation and
you haven't found the success that you
were looking for in terms of that first
off what's your overall pitch when
you're contacting my overall pitch
starts with I have film that's in
post-production right now I'm titled
killing with some Jones it was directed
by Joel David Moore who's incredibly
talented and it's starring Richard
Dreyfuss and Danny Glover and Danny
Masterson Jon Heder
Joely Fisher Tyler Labine lesley-ann
Brandt a lot of fantastic actors I tried
to name them all because we're quite
close now and kind of a tight-knit
family but so that's in post-production
we are looking to be released on
multiple platforms next year you know in
theaters we'll probably do a film
festival run so I have that going on at
the moment I am also in development on
my most recent scripts which Joel David
Moore will be directing as well we are
approaching ICM where he's represented
to be packaging it we brought on Barbara
Fiorentina who's a casting director a
very talented casting director in town
and she is helping us start to put
together a package and attach clients so
were we just had Jon Heder
who's most well-known for Napoleon
Dynamite attached himself he's a close
friend of mine very talented actor we
just spoke with another actor Alan Tudyk
and we're having discussions with Sam
Rockwell so trying to put together a
full package for this project insanity
please
I actually Jon Heder and I are also
writing a project together it's a we're
adapting a short by an Israeli writer
Eckart carats called fat so we're
adapting that in
to a feature and we're in negotiations
right now with Ram Bergman who owns the
rights to the to the short who is a very
accomplished producer about writing that
for him he produced Don John recently it
just came out as well as looper one of
my favorite films actually brick he
produced as well which is a film by Rian
Johnson who wrote and directed it I
think Rian Johnson is one of the most
talented writers that we have past
decade but I'm so working on that as
well I have a TV show actually that I'm
executive producing with Joel Moore as
well that we're packaging at underground
with trevor Angleton and Evan Silverberg
and we're gonna be taken to ICM as well
and then taking out two networks so
we're discussing with AMC and Showtime
and Netflix and HBO and let's see I
oh I'm also actually negotiating the
story rights the life rights for a
biopic of a 70s 60s and 70s soul singer
by the name of Wayne Cochran that I'm
hopefully going to be getting those
rights in writing this year as well and
a feature the great recollection and
among other projects so I have a lot of
projects that are that I'm working on
currently and taking out so those are
usually the projects that I talk to
agents and managers about and you know I
I just try to pitch them on the fact
that killing Winston Jones will be
coming out soon and these are the other
projects that I'm really excited about
and these are the people that are
attached to try to pique their interest
let's go back because when you are
contacting these individuals how do you
even know where to contact them are you
going to IMDB and you're looking for the
top 10 and
you will do way down to what's your
process my process is a little bit more
of using the connections utilizing the
connections that I made at innovative
and at CAA when I was there I think it's
always better to be introduced to an
agent or a manager rather than just cold
calling or just sending an email out of
the blue or even if you have some sort
of connection to the agent or the
manager it helps out more so for me you
know I I spoke with people over
innovative because originally Joel was
represented at innovative artists that's
actually where I met him when I was
working there and they were loosely
representing me helping the project
along for killing Liston Jones but and
then ICM ended up taking over doing that
so I spoke with some people over at ICM
it's really I like I said I utilize my
connections so I I call in some favors
from people who are represented at at
innovative or at ICM or at Gersh or at
you know the cartel or you know the firm
whatever it is and I really try to go to
a spectrum of agencies and management
companies anywhere from the you know the
smaller boutiques to the to the top ones
and test the waters and see you know if
I can gain representation I think the
the reason why I haven't been successful
to this point is because it's basically
twofold one is that agents and managers
want to see results so if you have a
certain amount of success that we've had
you know with with killing myths and
Jones and and we're moving into that
territory with innovative or with
insanity pleas that's still not
necessarily enough you know managers and
agents have huge client lists they're
extremely busy they need someone who is
going it's a business they need someone
who's going to be able to bring them
projects that are gonna make money you
know so I think that at the end of the
day when killing winston jones is real
if we go through the film festival
circuit and we you know open at Sundance
or South by Southwest or Toronto or
wherever we end up if there's any sort
of reception any sort of you know
hopefully accolades or something some
recognition I think that all those doors
that are cracked will probably fly out
them because then you'll see the results
of what was you know what was on paper
that's now a film that has received a
certain amount of success so I think
that will be helpful and a lot of those
you know those doors that were shut will
open and then I think the other thing
why I haven't had the amount of success
that I've wanted to or gain that
representation is also because film is
in a very delicate place right now and
it's difficult I don't know that you
know a lot of agents and a lot of
managers are looking to represent people
that are in television I'm not speaking
for everyone I'm just saying that
television can be more lucrative because
if you're successful at it you see
constant results you're writing on a
show if you get picked up for a season
you have multiple episodes that is much
more lucrative than writing on a film
you know I can't remember where I read
this but basically when you write a film
when you're finished writing that film
it's if you're lucky the best-case
scenario is it's probably going to take
you about 18 months to three years to
see that on the film on the screen or to
get it done or to get into production
it's just a long process whereas
television if you can pitch an idea get
it ordered to pilot get it done you can
see results very quickly and those
results are exponential if you're
successful and so I think that you know
me having come from the film world
writing features primarily in dramas and
dark comedies I didn't have television
and I think that was kind of like a
demerit you know that was a check
against me so I had agent manager agents
and managers telling me come back to us
when you are writing some television as
well and that's how I got into this TV
project that I'm working on now and I
think it's
it's making me a bit more competitive so
hopefully that will help me eventually
get you know the representation that I
think is extremely important in this
industry
you